Prefer aerobic aerobic exercise
Because it makes me feel able to fly.
Only then can I enjoy the purity of mind.
Acrobatic exercises are not limited to strength
But also rely on trust.
We rely on trust to help
People who have a sense of hearing to communicate with those who lack this sense.
Hearing impaired people are unable to communicate.
We are unable to communicate with them.
The importance of strengthening cohesion in society has thus emerged
So that everyone is equal in this society.
We are all sons of Adam.
"Manil" is the co-founder and CEO of Visualfy
Which provides an application with its name and converts sound into visual and sensory alerts.
Manil Alkaydi
Player acrobat
Application Developer
Celebrate application developers around the world
Share your story using #IMakeApps
g.co/play/imakeapps